Good morning.
Welcome to talks at Google in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Today.
It's my great privilege and pleasure to introduce Sherry Turkle.
Dr Turkle is professor of the social studies of science and technology at Mit.
She's a sociologist and clinical psychologist,
it leading media scholar who spent the last three decades studying our
relationship with the digital culture where you've created or classic studies in
the field or the second self life on the screen and alone together.
She joins us today to discuss her latest book reclaiming conversation,
the power of talk in a digital age,
emphasis here on the power.
I found this book and eloquent,
profound,
and often moving examination of the consequences of our addiction to our devices
for ourselves and our families,
and how conversation,
which we may dimly recall as an interaction between two or more humans in which
no devices are involved can help.
Please join me in welcoming Sherry Turkle.
Yeah,
well that was a lovely introduction and what was loveliest about it is that I
think it,
it touches on the fact that this really is a book of my heart.
Um,
the other books I've written and I,
I'm dedicated to all of them.
All books.
Do you like your children?
Um,
basically came out of my doing sponsored by the NSF or you know,
kind of other funders,
10,
15 years of work,
five,
10,
15 years of work and then reporting out on what I had found.
And this book began in a somewhat different way at the end of loan together,
which was the book about I kind of new social situation that people found
themselves in.
We'd all be here.
Uh,
so we were together,
we were in a social situation of some stores,
but um,
we often found ourselves feeling um,
uh,
that we could find a sort of place alone in our heads in a new kind of way.
Cause we could go to our phones and being a different kind of space or flip
Bitch,
oh,
we would be alone in our apartments or I'm in a park or wherever,
but we would feel ourselves more together with the world,
with our communities,
with,
I mean,
I knew kind of global together that that was absolutely unprecedented.
So that was the,
the topic of that book really was what was the psychology of what were the new
political dynamics?
What was the feeling of that new state?
Um,
at the end of that book,
as I listened to the transcripts and gone over the hundreds and hundreds of
transcripts,
particularly from young people,
but not just from young people,
no one phrase kept coming up,
something that I really hadn't had a chance to explore in that book,
which was I'd rather text than talk as part of the kind of situation of people
who now had the devices that enabled this alone together state,
these new always on,
always on new technologies that enabled this new thing I was studying and I'm a
psychologist and,
um,
I'm psychodynamically trained,
which means that I'm interested in sort of interpersonal dynamics,
the importance of early childhood,
the boards of communication and connection in early childhood.
The importance of empathy and its development in early childhood.
Um,
and I thought to myself,
okay,
let's take seriously,
you know,
instead of taking this as the litany or catchphrase,
let's really take seriously.
If people tell me they'd rather text than talk.
If you're really doing that,
let me explore this like an ethnography.
Let me follow this story in business and romance and the raising of children and
how people are getting along in their communities and their,
with their colleagues,
with their lovers,
with their families,
with their friends.
Let me follow the story and what will that mean in all of these areas of life.
And so that's why I'm trained.
I'm trained to be an ethnographer and essentially that's what we claiming
conversation is.
It's a look at for me,
a much broader sweep of data because I did go into law firms and doctor's
offices,
you know,
the kinds of doctor's offices where literally doctors are looking at screens
instead of talking to patients because they're forced to,
to law firms where people felt it was more important to stay at their screens,
then go to lunch with their colleagues.
Big Mistake if you're a lawyer and want to get promoted.
Um,
big mistake in terms of the culture of those firms.
But yet that's how they felt about it.
Software companies where people had the right kind of cafeterias and micro
kitchens to sit down and have a conversation,
except the highest value of the company was that they'd be always on the
messaging system in order to show their devotion.
So I went to all kinds of places,
as I say,
a much broader sweep of the world.
And I studied this issue of conversation.
So what did I find?
Well maybe it makes sense to say what I find by starting with a story,
which is not a feel good story for me.
At the end of the book was published and I'm just waiting for it to come out
before it comes out in New York Times reporter calls me.
Um,
my publisher hadn't wanted me talking,
you know,
talking much before the book comes out.
This such a,
an event and the New York Times reporter calls me and he wants me to now and
finally allowed to talk about the book.
He wants me to comment on a story he's writing about Hello Barbie.
So Hello Barbie is a robot doll that comes out of the box and says,
hello.
I'm Barbie.
I think I love you.
I have a sister.
I don't like her so much.
I think I'm jealous of her.
I hear you have a sister.
Are you jealous of your sister?
Let's talk.
In other words,
it comes out of the box with a pretend empathy narrative and starts to try to
engage you in conversation about this pretend empathy narrative with the idea
that that will be,
does this pretend best friend thing?
That will be conversation.
So
my position on this,
you know,
everything I know about kids growing up and from studying social robotics and
how kids respond to it is that you can get a kid to talk to a robot that offers
pretend empathy,
but you can't get a child to learn and experience empathy from a robot that has
none to give because this robot hasn't known a life,
it doesn't have a sister.
It doesn't know what jealousy is.
In other words,
this is not,
this conversation is not going to do the job that conversation needs to do.
So it turns out after you know,
studying law offices and business offices and you know,
families.
Now,
there was another part of the story in fact to which in fact I do end the book
on the issue of robotics,
but Hello Barbie wasn't on the market.
You know,
I would have ended the book with Hello Barbie had it hadn't been.
It turns out that sociable robotics is also part of this story of kind of a
crisis of conversation because we're offering ourselves and our children objects
that are full conversation.
So just to give you some sense of all the ways we can't learn empathy now in our
culture and yet there's an empathy crisis and I'm going to argue just to give
the argument of that I'm going to make today and that I'm making reclaiming
conversation the to this empathy crisis conversation is the remedy.
And to make a bad pun,
I call it the talking cure,
and that in fact is where the book began with a 40% drop in all markers for
empathy among college students.
It was a Meta analysis that looked at many surveys,
many studies over the past 20 years.
There's this 40% drop among college students in many markets for empathy.
Most vet in the past 10 years.
And I,
and in,
in our conversation,
uh,
because I'm only going to talk for about half my time,
um,
it's telling that the very brilliant woman who was the head of this study after
learning this decided to write empathy apps for the iPhone.
So the whole question of
let us grant that part of the way we got ourselves into some trouble with
empathy,
which is borne from looking at someone in the eye,
not breaking that contact,
hearing what they have to say they're hearing back.
Would you have to say taking some time,
let us grant that,
interrupting that by going like,
this is part of the problem.
To what degree do we want to solve it with this technology that we have always
on hand,
how much are we going to look to technology to solve the problem that perhaps
technology got us into?
It obviously is very seductive to do that,
but is that a good idea?
So I found out that,
um,
I began to get more evidence about the,
the empathy,
the empathy crisis when I was called in to consult in middle schools for a much
younger students than college students.
Um,
and in one school in particular in the book,
I call it the Holbrook school,
the teachers were saying that the students bout 12 year old students were
behaving like eight year old students.
There were showing a kind of cruelty their fellow students,
not on the Internet,
I mean not kind of in cyber bullying situations,
but really the teachers were saying,
they didn't seem to understand how other students were feeling when other
students were talking to them.
I mean they essentially were describing a crisis of empathy and they didn't seem
to get it when their teachers spoke to them.
They said 12 year old students behave like eight year old students.
So with was a very dramatic study for me.
All these places where I was finding teachers and um,
educators of did a large study of kind of teachers and all kinds of educators in
that age range who were all talking about kind of the same thing.
But then there were group of studies that were truly optimistic.
And then I want to share with you in only five days without phones in a summer
camp,
that's device free.
Young people get those empathy markers to come right back up.
In other words,
we are built to have an empathic response to each other know how did they get
those empathy markers to come back up.
They talked to each other,
they talk to each other without turning away from each other to look for a
device.
So why would we,
you know,
getting back to the Barbie and getting back to the fact that most kids have
phones when they're five or six or seven,
why would we give kids just at the time when they're developing that empathic
response,
why would we want to give children an object that will block the development of
empathy and phones do block the development of empathy?
Not because we met them too.
It's not kind of a sub because we said,
oh,
we're going to just,
you know,
invent something that's really going to get in the way of empathy.
It's just because when you go like that to a person,
you're putting them on pause and your saying that you can't attend to what
they're thinking or feeling.
Now the more developed an older the person is,
you know,
the less let's say damage it's going to do,
but a series of studies show that if you are sitting at a table and you put a
phone,
a silent phone on the table between you,
you will feel less.
First of all the conversation will go to trivial matters.
The topic of the conversation will change.
It will not be about important things.
And secondly you will feel less empathic connection with the person you're
talking to.
And then they redid this study in a natural setting where they put the phone,
not between two people having lunch but in the periphery of the landscape.
Kind of like if you put the phone almost where I couldn't see it at the edge of
the stage and had me talking to you know,
somebody at lunch.
But th th th the phones is almost like at the next table and they got the same
results
conversation on things less important and less sensitive commitment and
connection,
lesson path exams with the person you're talking with.
Essentially.
It makes every kind of sense that if people think they're going to be
interrupted,
their attitude toward a conversation changes.
It's really as simple as that.
Um,
and college students know that.
They know that they don't pay attention to each other when they have their
phones.
And they talked to me about something they called the rule of threes and it's a
lot of my own research took place on college campuses.
So one young man says to me,
um,
introducing the rule of three,
because at the beginning I had been thinking of doing a study really on the,
um,
on the nature of texting,
on the diction of texting,
really getting deeply into the kind of linguistics of texting.
And he said,
don't do that.
It's not our texting.
He says that's getting us into trouble.
It's what our texting is doing to our in person conversations.
And that's really was my Lodestar for this study,
if not our texting that's getting us into trouble.
He said it's what our texting is doing to our in person conversations.
And I said,
well tell me more.
And to illustrate this,
I'd get the story about the rule of three.
And here's the rule of three.
When you're at dinner,
let's say it's six,
it's three people have to have their heads up before you get,
give yourself permission to put your head down to texts cause everybody has
their phone and everybody's going to be texting at dinner.
So the rule of three is a kind of new politeness about when you can let your po,
your attention go down.
So what is the result of the rule of three?
It's exactly the result of all those studies that took place with the silent
phone on the table.
That kind of silenced that change the nature of discussion and gave people less
than an empathic connection with each other.
Things are kept light and on subjects will you don't mind being interrupted and
people feel less of an empathic connection with each other and then it's not
just among college students.
I mean,
I should mention a recent pew study showed that 89% of adults say that in their
last social interaction they took out a phone and 82% say that it diminished the
conversation.
Now that said,
he goes on to be very realistic and very positive and very kind of upbeat about
all the great things people did when they took out their phone.
They looked up a movie,
they,
I mean they,
they looked up a cinematographer,
they checked a a thing in their neighborhood.
I mean they,
you know,
phone is completely integrated in their life,
but bottom line,
89% interrupted social interaction.
82% of,
let's say it less than the conversation rule of three.
And then there's the rule of seven.
The rule of seven is what a college junior described as this.
It takes seven minutes to know whether a congress,
where a conversation is going to go.
You have to just like it probably takes seven minutes to know like whether
you're going to pay close attention to that.
You have to get used to do,
you know somebody's body in the room.
The way somebody speaks,
the kind of cadence,
how they express themselves,
but certainly in a conversation where you're kind of adjusting to each other,
there are fits in there.
It starts,
there are lows.
It takes seven minutes to sort of see whether this is going to be worth her
time.
She explains to me and then she says,
I often don't put in my seven minutes because I just would rather go to the
phone and get the reliability of that sort of steady feed.
It's easier to just a text during those seven minutes.
It's easier to get something sure and certain and it's more efficient
and a lot of people I interviewed said that that day don't put in that kind of
time or wait for that kind of low or allow themselves a moment of boredom in
conversations today before that happens.
They go to a phone so you can see a kind of perfect storm building up here.
All roads led me to a crisis in a certain kind of conversation.
It's not like we're not talking,
I'm talking about the kind of conversation that's spontaneous,
open ended where they're tangents will you allow yourself lows?
Will you don't interrupt each other where there's eye contact,
the kind of thing where empathy is born,
where creativity is most likely to happen and crisis in empathy is happening and
I'm arguing the conversation is the talking cure conversation.
That kind of conversation is the most human and humanizing thing that we know
how to do.
That doesn't take away in the slightest from the fun and the intellectual
qualities and the sexiness and the eroticism and the joy of texting and email
and messaging and everything.
I mean just everything.
It just means the conversation has some particularities even in our
neurophysiology.
That makes it the ideal thing for teaching empathy and for getting certain kinds
of results in creativity,
collaboration and developing the human.
It's the training ground for empathy and I'm not saying to put away your phones
for certain amount of time because it's polite or because I want you to learn
some kind of art of conversation to be kind of fancy talkers.
I'm really saying that this flight and from conversation,
the fact that we don't want to sit around for the boring bits is one woman said
to me,
I don't like the boring bits is actually interfering with something we need to
do for each other as human beings.
You know,
and they're,
they're a great ironies.
As I said,
even though the psychologists are agreeing on this crisis and empathy,
there's this big movement to create these empathy apps does getting ourselves
into trouble and wanting technology to cure it just as people are intolerant of
being alone and want technology to cure that.
You.
Many of you may have heard of a study that's become widely cited in which a
group of college students,
this was part of a group of 21 studies,
but in this one study at the University of Virginia Group of college,
students were asked,
um,
they were told that they were going to be asked to sit alone from six to 15
minutes.
And were they okay with that?
Sure.
No devices,
no book.
Sure.
Um,
did they think they might want to give themselves electric shocks during that
period?
No,
not really.
Uh,
no.
They're asked to test the shocking though they'd tested it.
There was no really not.
Um,
and then they would just ask to sit alone without a device.
After six minutes,
the students were shocking themselves.
So being alone was so intolerable that they would rather give themselves
electric shocks than sit quietly with their own thoughts.
Being alone is a problem that we want technology to solve.
And I bring this up because there's actually an important connection that I want
to leave you with between.
It's like if you leave with one thing,
it's sort of like this is the thing to leave with this important connection
between conversation and solitude because I think this is where my work is often
misunderstood.
They'll say,
well,
sure.
Sherry Turkle says,
the problem,
if we're looking at our devices when we're together,
okay,
granted that that's not so cool,
but what about if I look at my device when I'm alone?
Was that bothering?
What does that,
that's not a problem for anybody.
You need to have a capacity for solitude in order to have a capacity for
sociality.
The company link between conversation and solitude is tremendous.
We cannot sell our flight from conversation or crisis of empathy without dealing
with our incapacity,
for solitude,
with our site,
with our flight for soft from solitude that it's only when you can gather
yourself,
be content with yourself and because of that,
talk to another person and really see who they are as a person and hear them for
who they are because you're okay with yourself.
Can you begin to have a conversation?
The way psychologists have put this so beautifully is that if you don't teach
your children to be alone,
they'll only know how to be lonely.
That solitude and sociality go together.
And that's why you can't just say,
oh well you know the devices.
Like you know,
I'll worry about the devices one on whether the people,
but whatever I do by myself,
my intolerance for having a moment alone,
that's nothing.
We have to be more intentional in our use of devices for ourselves,
not just because we're breaking up conversations with other people.
So what I'm basically saying is that we're at a kind of Rachel Carson moment
distracted at our dinner tables and living rooms at business meetings and in
classrooms.
I see traces of the new silence spring.
That's the term that Carson coined when we were ready to see that with
technological change had come and assault on our environment.
And now we've arrived at another moment of recognition.
I think people,
you know what?
When I wrote a loan together,
people thought it was a good book,
but people want to fight with me.
I mean it was like,
okay,
that's a really good book.
Let's fight about this and now I really feel that we've arrived at a moment of
recognition when people feel that something is amiss,
something is amiss.
We have a great technology but something is amiss.
We need to get it more aligned with the lives we want to leave this time.
Technology is implicated in an assault on empathy.
Rachel Carson's moment was a moment of recognition that we were at a point where
we had to do something and we could do something and now too we can do
something.
We can do many somethings,
many somethings both in how we design technology.
I'm delighted to be speaking here,
delighted to be here and how we use technology.
There are many something so I'm just going to quickly rushed through a couple of
these little somethings.
It was not to take too much more than seven minutes on all the things to do and
then I hope that in the questions we can open up to more somethings.
These,
some things sound like little,
some things,
but when you add them together,
it's the change in culture.
We're not looking for solutions.
We're looking for first steps.
So what are some first steps?
First of all,
act with intention.
A father is getting his two year old daughter a bath and he's on,
he's,
he's doing his mail with on the iPhone and he says to me,
I remember giving my 11 year old daughter a bath when she was two and he used to
just sit with her and talked to her and sing to her and play the little play
with the little toy she had in her bathtub.
I kind of missed that with my two year old.
I play,
uh,
I,
I don't do that.
I just do my mail on my iPhone.
Technology makes us forget what we know about life.
That's author's choice.
That's my fear.
That's my favorite line in my book.
Technology makes us forget what we know about life.
He knows that he is doing something that's not,
that's a mess.
That little girl needs some conversation from her dad and he enjoyed and was
nurtured himself by talking to his older child.
At a moment like this,
pull up your socks,
put your,
pull yourself together and put down the phone.
So Act with intention,
participate however you can,
and a revitalization of public conversation.
Um,
because public conversations teach us,
they model how conversation can unfold to many of my students say they don't
know how to have a public conversation.
They don't know how to have a conversation.
Their families,
they say their families didn't talk at dinner.
I lay a lot of this on parents.
It was my generation that thought we would only get a dick Tracy to weigh risk
radio.
That was like the best we would ever get.
And I've been,
all of a sudden I have a smartphone and like this is like amazing and we didn't
talk to our kids.
It's parents who didn't talk at breakfast and dinner.
It's kids who were telling me that they're,
that they never took a walk with their father to the corner store when the
father didn't have his phone with them.
So it's very important that we have public conversations,
including classrooms where there's a lot of talk,
which is part of my problem with putting everything on screens and distance
learning.
Not that it itself isn't good,
but you have to worry every time you take conversation away from the classroom.
Remember that the presence of a device already signals that your attention is
divided even if you do not intend it to be.
So remember those studies at phones on the table.
Remember that when you put that phone on the table,
you were signaling that you could be elsewhere,
even if you don't mean to go elsewhere.
So do the simplest thing.
Just don't put it on the table except what research has made clear.
And you've heard this so many times,
it's so boring.
Anyway,
just listen to me.
Unitasking is the next big thing.
There is no such thing as multitasking.
Do one thing at a time.
Really be in the vanguard.
It is.
Everybody knows this.
Nobody wants to hear it.
So I said it,
you know,
it's true.
Conversation is the human way to practice.
Unitasking part of the reason it's,
um,
why it's so hard.
Don't try to be perfect.
My students come to me and they say they do not want to go to office hours.
They want to write me an email instead of office hours.
What do they want to write me an email?
Because they will write the email that best expresses their question and I will
write them an email back that perfectly answers there.
You know,
that's perfectly pitched and gives them the most information back.
It's a transaction and it's perfect.
Who developed a love of knowledge,
a love of learning and I here today because I asked the perfect question and
somebody gave me a perfect answer.
No,
there was no one who developed a love of learning for that reason.
It's because somebody sat down with me,
believed in me because I looked at somebody in a conversation and said,
I could be like that person.
I could be,
what would it take for me to be like that person and that person is talking to
me and interested in me.
That's how it happens.
Cultivate solitude.
The capacity to be alone with your thoughts is crucial.
Some of the most crucial conversations you're going to have our conversations
with yourself to have them,
you have to learn to listen with your own voice,
set aside your laptops and your tablets and put away your phone
and finally obey the seven minute rule.
That's the rule suggested to me by a college junior that says that it takes at
least seven minutes to see how a conversation is going to unfold.
You have to let it unfold and not go to your phone before those minutes pass.
If there is a lull in the conversation,
let it be.
Every technology challenges are human values,
which is a good thing because it causes us to reflect on what these values are.
If we've invented a technology that causes us to look at each other less to make
less eye contact,
that needs to be a signal to us and the message of my book is that we're all in
this together.
Let's just look up,
look at each other and start the conversation.
Thank you very much.
Okay,
so questions?
Yes,
a previous generations have or last generation anyway.
Um,
tended to use television when they didn't want to be alone.
That kind of sense of,
you know,
breaking the loneliness and from what I understand from recent studies,
the use of television that way is decreasing to some degree as people are
spending more time either online or potentially online with some sort of chat.
Do you think that this decrease in empathy,
that people actually got som modeled conversation,
modeled empathy in Pv and that the decrease in TV is potentially a bad thing?
As weird as that sounds.
I mean,
how,
how do you compare TV as a form of using that?
Well,
well
I think TV is that we,
let me just say a word about TV.
I in,
in reclaiming conversation,
I talk a lot about TV because TV,
we've all experienced TV and it's very important not to get into,
oh well we're talking about the latest technology and then we're just,
we're just upset about this one because the one we have now and then we were
upset about TV when that was the thing.
What,
what is the reason I'm on?
I was a big,
I don't want to say computer diva because that would be a little much,
but I was on the cover of,
believe it or not,
I was on the cover of wired magazine for being a kind of booster of this
technique is it seems like very early days,
but in fact it was true that I was very,
and it juiciest and the difference between,
so before I answer your question,
what this device has that other devices don't TV anything.
The uniqueness of this device is the always on,
always on new property where you can,
every interaction you're in,
like your baby being with your baby.
There are,
there are potty trainers that have a slot for the IPAD,
there are baby bouncers with a slot for the IPAD.
There are,
and,
and to me,
those signify our kind of willingness to interrupt every time that normally we
would be thinking of the human gaze and the human talk to a baby,
which is built into us as what the baby needs as potentially broken by a screen.
So that the fact of those objects in the culture are symptoms of the fact that
we have still gotten so used to this always on,
always on u s situation,
a television.
I grew up with a television,
my family sat around it and we all talk to the television.
There was this program,
I remember Mama on the television that are an immigrant family and we all fought
with the television about what that family did and how our family would have
done it differently and and how they're making big mistakes and what they're
doing with their money.
Television didn't have to be isolating.
It could be isolating.
We have to find a way to make our current technologies less isolating.
I mean,
it's kind of like a,
to television as a perfect example for me of how it's not the object,
it's the designing for vulnerability around the object.
We are vulnerable to certain kinds of uses of our phones that are not really
nurturing of us as a co,
as individuals in a collective.
And we have to design around that vulnerability to make that relationship
better.
I mean,
that's how I see it.
But I don't know about television modeling empathy in our troubles with empathy.
I have to think about that.
That's,
uh,
I'll get back to you.
We'll,
we'll talk more about that.
The idea that not enough television is the root of,
this is something I,
I have to admit that's a,
that's a toughie.
Your work is on the level of sort of peer interaction and it's very fascinating
and frightening to me.
Both.
Um,
I wanted to ask you about two areas that are related but are on a kind of a
different scale.
Um,
20 years ago,
Robert Putnam wrote bowling alone about the decline of civic participation
society.
Um,
he wrote that between 1995 and 2000,
he was looking back to 1950.
Um,
it's talking about the client of voting of civic organizations,
even things like bowling legs,
hence the title of the book.
And they're clearly,
there are a lot of things that play into this,
including,
you know,
residential mobility and all kinds of stuff.
But he did in fact link it to technology,
uh,
notably TV,
the rise of TV.
And later the Internet over that whole period.
I'm just wondering,
I know you didn't directly study,
you know,
things like a wider organizations,
but I'm wondering if you have any thoughts about whether this might be related
to that.
That's number one and number two,
um,
uh,
a slightly different sort of thing.
I wonder if you have any thoughts about whether this kind of trend is in any way
related to the recent,
a huge increase in diagnosis of autism and autistic disorders.
Well,
let me take the second first.
I'm not an autism expert,
so I,
I,
I say this kind of bracketed with that disclaimer,
but I know for a fact that in the schools that I was studying that were not
schools specifically not schools for children who had developmental disorders or
autism or were on the spectrum
children,
we're not looking at each other in the eye.
We're having conversations with their heads down,
did not show empathy towards the other child,
other children.
In one case,
I report in the book again in a school that is not for children on the spectrum.
A child,
one child's father had committed suicide and another girl says to him,
I hope you go the way of your dad when she didn't lock,
when she wanted to talk to his sister more in the lunch room and you know,
honestly a 13 year old fight.
And when the headmaster tries to talk to her about this and he said to me,
his goal was to make that girl cry,
you know,
that would,
and then he had to call his or her mother to explain why she came home in tears.
I mean,
you know,
to try to get her head into the head of this other kid.
He said it was almost impossible.
In other words,
you have children acting as though they were on the spectrum and the knee,
the in the camps where children go and have a summer without phones.
One of the things the counselors note is the children come in kind of heads
down,
not talking,
having a very hard time relating to other kids.
And by the end of the summer it's often,
it's often as long as a 10 week or 12 week session.
Um,
they taste they're,
so,
I,
I fear that we're misdiagnosing all his kids who really have a different kind of
disorder,
which is that they,
they're,
they're out of a kind of practice and I mean this quite literally,
they're out of a kind of practice of,
of,
of meeting to deal with the complexities of a conversation and we're diagnosing
them perhaps as on the spectrum when really they need the talking cure because,
um,
I'll tell you just one piece of this.
Children don't apologize.
They say they type I'm sorry,
and they hit send and the elements of an apology,
which is looking you in the eye seeing that you are hurt.
Okay,
your seeing that I'm upset that I see that you're hurt,
you feeling compassionate because you see that I'm upset my seeing,
oh my God,
he looks compassionate.
Maybe there's a chance for me and you're seeing that.
I want to take that chance.
This is a very,
very complicated dance and this is how empathy is born.
We're doing all of this,
putting each other and the in the turn of the other,
I'm sorry,
on and hitting send does none of this work.
So I'm saying that I see a lot,
I have a lot of optimism and just giving kids more of an opportunity.
And this is where I want to get back to Robert Putnam.
When you're not sending a kid out on the street,
when you're,
when he's not part of that boy scout troop,
would that afterschool thing where that little league or that,
you know,
I recently had a reunion.
One lovely thing about getting your book with you,
The New York Times as you all of a sudden you're meeting people you went to
kindergarten with.
You know,
because they,
I mean it's like,
you know,
they,
oh my God,
Sherry,
you know,
I can go to your book towards signing.
You know,
I always went to kindergarten with you.
So I'm going to having like all these wonderful reunions and we're all talking
about how much time we spent on the street does in Brooklyn.
We spent a lot of,
this is pre bowling alone.
We bowled together.
I mean we didn't bowl,
we played the other games,
but hopscotch or tag or,
but we were on the street and all of those interactions were part of communities
where people were constantly negotiating.
We're kids,
we're constantly learning these skills.
So I see my work as the,
she hung inside the micro side,
the personal side,
the opening up the door of the how the home side of what Robert Putnam is
talking about.
So I feel very close to the work of,
of Putnam and other people like him who were talking about the macro was my
work,
excuse me,
focuses more on the micro.
Yeah.
Good morning.
The um,
I love what technology is doing in schools right now for the most part in terms
of enabling collaboration between students and things like that.
Uh,
but it's the same.
It's the same.
A lot of the same opportunities for avoidance and,
um,
being alone are created with the screens.
So talk a little bit about what you think schools might need to do or could do
to help mitigate against,
you know,
pushing us faster down the path.
You're talking about number one and number two,
have you heard from maybe corporations at all,
uh,
around the training implications for this,
for communications,
particularly in a selling environment?
Um,
you know,
go to a sale.
I'm,
I'm a sales leader here.
Um,
everyone has a device or two or three at every meeting you go to.
So from what you've described,
that means that automatically empathy has gone from the meeting and empathy as a
key part for in salesmanship.
So if you could talk about that for a minute too.
Let me start with that.
Here's a great chapter in my book on business and my favorite,
my favorite story is,
um,
is a,
is a guy who says,
I cannot make,
you know,
I cannot close the deal unless I have a conversation and I have to get,
and I cannot tell you how many times he tells me that I will send out an email
and,
and uh,
they'll want to send me an email back and I know that I need to see this person.
I need to have his device away and for me to close this deal and,
and I have to work so hard to get him at least on the phone or hopefully face to
face to really make the money I need.
Or people talk at length about people who do not,
who just want to send emails back and forth instead of really closing,
you know,
instead of really dealing with a problem or who will not put there or the
struggle to get the highest levels to put their devices away during very
important meetings.
And I'm seeing a big shift in willingness to start to force people to put their
devices away because really to get things done,
you,
you need full attention.
So I think we're just at the cusp.
I mean,
I want this project to be part of,
you know,
no,
no one book changes people's,
I mean,
I don't expect you guys to read this book and say,
Oh,
you know,
now my mind is changed completely,
but I want this to,
I think I've assembled a lot of data that should start a good conversation about
phones and business.
I know in my work setting,
five years ago,
professors were,
I am not anybody's nanny.
I don't want to be anybody's nanny.
You come to class,
you do whatever you want.
I'm nobody's nanny.
And now with all the new data that is in about how one open laptop not only
destroys the attention of the person with the open laptop,
but it kind of circle around that person.
We have baskets and we say put,
put the phone and put the laptop in the basket and then come into class.
The professors are now have a totally different attitude about this.
There's a story in the book about Carol Steiker at the Harvard business school
who five years ago,
six years ago,
had everybody,
you know,
taking notes on laptops.
She thought that was the way,
okay,
sure.
Everybody,
that's how people,
right.
And then she says that she found that when they had their laptops open,
people would transcribing the class.
They weren't integrating what was happening in the class.
They were doing a trial like they were court snog refers and her law school
class at Harvard.
So,
and then one day one of the students was sick,
she was in the hospital and different members of the class had offered to take
notes for this sick girl.
And a student comes up to her and says,
Professor Saker,
I,
I need to have your notes today because my,
my,
my power was lost.
I didn't have a power cord.
And she said,
well why didn't you take notes by hand?
well I couldn't do that.
I couldn't get it all down if I took notes by hand.
So the whole thing that she wants her students to do,
which is to integrate,
which is to integrate what you hear and make sense of it for you,
which you can do by hand.
The student had level was not even like on the program that she would even think
of doing that.
All she knows how to do is take everything down in a laptop.
And that's the day that Steiker said no more computers in class.
So to your point about schools,
I go into classrooms and students are just using these devices in ways that are
fantastic mind blowing.
And there's a lot of use of these computers in ways that are mine deadening and
now it's our job to sort this through and it's,
it's a big job because I have,
there are some of the most hysterical stories in my book.
I think our students who print out their reading assignments because it's too
distracting to read them on the computer that their school gave them because
they're too,
they're too tempted to look at other things and let their minds wander so that's
what you don't want so you have to,
it's not enough to just put the computers in class.
You have to be now it's the second generation we all have to like get very
vigilant about what about the culture of the classroom that we use the men and I
really think schools should not close their libraries.
Very,
very bad choice.
Very bad choice.
Putting everything on the machine and thinking libraries are gone.
Very bad choice
is that my phone,
my daughter who works for Linkedin,
God telling me something,
she's 24 she works for Linkedin,
says that only someone over 40 ever forgets to turn over their phone.
Off their phone.
That's very funny.
Yes.
Hi.
Uh,
how do you deal with the idea that more and more time being spent on devices is
being used to be more productive,
be emails or reading articles or because Internet has so much information,
so all the additional time that it's been used to spend on devices is being used
to be more productive and anything,
any time that is spent in solitude is sort of wasted time or so to speak.
Well,
I honor your question
and how can I say in the nicest possible way,
the premise is wrong.
The premise,
the time and solitude reading a male is without any further qualifier,
productive,
the most productive way you could be spending your time is part of what we have
to examine because it turns out not to be true.
And the premise,
the time in solitude,
getting more information online is the most productive way to be spending your
time instead of,
for example,
and it just may sound crazy to you,
but it's by hearing something that sounds crazy,
that you kind of say,
Oh,
let me think about this crazy thing and I'll let me entertain this idea.
Mind wandering,
letting your imagination wander.
We're terrified of that idea.
People like,
oh,
I want to stay with my computer.
I want to stay on my machine when we now have a device that lets us do that.
Unless us feel that we're always productive.
That's why we want to be at it.
I mean,
we wouldn't be in this,
probably wouldn't be having this problem if this thing didn't seduce us with the
promise that we're more productive when we're at it.
So that's why I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm so sympathetic with your premise because that's how we feel when we're with
it.
I sometimes say it makes us three promises,
like gifts of the benevolent ferry.
You will always be productive.
You will always be,
you can go where you can let your imagination go wherever it wants to go.
You will always be her.
You will never be bored and you know when now you'll always be productive.
You'll or you'll never be wasting time.
You'll never,
and just turns out that,
that,
that we've sort of,
um,
it's like multitasking.
The great studies of bi,
of multitasking by,
by Clifford Nass,
who tragically died a few years ago,
showed that when people multitask,
they feel like they're doing better and better and better and better every for
every task they add,
when in fact they're doing worse and worse.
Every test they add,
they feel they're doing better at every task and in fact are doing worse than
every task.
And we have to force ourselves to reconsider that.
That extra time at our email is,
is,
is not timed.
It's really the most productive and the most collaborative.
That's why I do case studies of companies where instead of allowing for
conversation and collaboration,
the,
the value of the company is to keep everybody at their screen and they're losing
out even though they're stating that really what they want is people talking and
collaborating because the pressure to stay at your screen is such an important
part of the company culture.
So that somebody asked about do I want to have an impact on businesses mean if I
had one impact on business,
that would be the conversation I would want to start.
I think.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
I was curious about when you were talking about kind of resilience of that just
a bit of time away helps rebuild that empathy.
Um,
and it's particularly interesting to me because I keep Shabbat,
so from Friday afternoon till Saturday night,
my phone is off,
no exceptions,
no computer,
no nothing.
And the community of people that I'm friends with and that I spend that time
with also have their phones off and I enjoy it.
Um,
and I'm curious if there's been any studies either examining the effect within
that sort of community,
but also I would imagine that that information would be very useful.
Applying outwards of what sort of techniques are useful and how much time away
has an effect on empathy and community.
Well,
actually there's a,
there's a,
there's a large community of people who are um,
working on the notion of sort of a digital Shabbat and who have kind of,
um,
but not necessarily making it a religious practice,
but you sort of using that experience and,
and many people find that it,
the 24 hours turns out to be almost ideal.
An ideal time.
Others,
others find that taking three hours a night is perfect.
Others find that.
So what people have,
what people have shown is that
is that there are many ways to do it.
And that what makes most sense for the beginning is for people to tune it to
their,
you know,
own family lives and their own,
kind of,
you know,
stories.
But certainly the one day once a week is ideal.
Many families take one and a half day vacation with a sort of literally go to a
different place where there's no internet,
where they do things together.
The the,
the part in,
in,
in the studies that were done,
I'm forgetting the name of the company,
it's a,
it's a large consulting company.
It's public information.
It'll come back to me.
I write about it.
They just haven't called predictable time off where they gave people only one
night a week.
But what you mentioned was very important.
You're in a community of people to talk about it and they didn't only give
people one night a week where they said,
you don't have to be on your phone,
but they had people talk about that experience when they came to work and they
gave them support at work,
more support perhaps in other workers had about the stresses of the always on
life.
And many people think that what is helpful about the Shabbat is that so many
people who were taking that Shabbat,
they're not just taking that Shabbat,
but they're taking that Shabbat and they're also in community with other people.
Which is why it makes it harder to study your experience and make it seem like,
oh,
well we'll just apply this to everybody and that will be the right recipe for
digital detox because you're having a combination of no digital but then an
extraordinary group community experience.
But I think people are trying different things.
It makes sense,
you know,
different people in different ways.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I liked your term seduction.
Um,
it's very easy to get on and stay on even though there's no reason to,
um,
to um,
uh,
to say,
well,
it's the easy thing to do just to stay on here.
Uh,
my question I guess is,
is there some way to use these tools more intentionally as you say,
Facebook,
for example,
Mike,
kindergarten friends,
sometimes I do see them on Facebook and said,
wow,
you know,
I had no idea you were in California.
You know,
what have you been doing for the last 50 years
or more?
Actually,
but,
um,
so,
you know,
but I on the other hand,
uh,
realizing that they've just spent an hour on Facebook,
I said,
what the hell have I been doing?
Right.
Is there some way to use tools like that more effectively?
More intentionally,
yes.
But I'm not sure that,
um,
but,
but you know,
again,
what is your intention?
I think,
I think we have to figure out if is it,
I now have an intention that I actually like from,
I've learned from this tour that I actually like connecting with the people I
knew when I was a kid in Brooklyn.
So when I'm on Facebook now,
I'm not wandering the plains of Facebook,
just hoping that somebody will bite me.
I actually kind of like,
you know,
if I spend some time there,
I'm actually feel motivated to look for the people who were on the masthead of
the Lincoln log at Abraham Lincoln High School in Brooklyn.
I don't feel that that's,
I think I feel that joyful and positive time online so that that's behavior with
intention.
I think the issue is behavior with intention.
When you're on the Internet with behavior,
with intention,
what's,
what's not to like it's,
I mean,
when,
when if students in our classes actually looked up something that was crucial to
the discussion,
broader to the class and said,
my God,
well here's the thing that's,
that's crucial to the discussion.
And then that was the end of it.
That'd be fine.
But that's not what happens.
They look it up and then they get,
they see a message and they'd go,
did they was one of my students says,
I can't bear not to see who wants me when she sees a message from Facebook.
And that's what it's about.
We all want to see who wants us there.
So you go to Facebook and then once you're there,
you see an ad and then we see we have the,
the trail and then you're buying rei sportswear.
I mean that's the sort of MIT trail from the,
from the,
from the factoid to the,
who wants me to the hub to enter to the choose to the hiking shoes.
So I think that the notion of acting with intention is the one that matters,
but you have to decide what your intention is for each of these,
for each of these things.
Thanks.
And this is the last question.
Okay.
Um,
I'm just wondering if you've looked at the difference between talking on the
phone with people and texting.
I've noticed that I used to,
if my wife had a conversation on the phone,
I over here,
part of what she's talking about,
you can ask questions about it later,
but if someone picks up a phone and looks at it,
it's all private.
Have you looked at the difference between texting and talking on,
well,
you know,
there was a wonderful,
and we talking about privacy and there's so much to discuss here,
but let me just give you,
just refer you to one wonderful piece of writing a woman in any issue of privacy
and texting and what you lose.
A woman recently wrote an op Ed in the New York Times about,
uh,
being a mother and the difference between being a mother and doing all of her
work for her children like this.
On the phone and the way her mother did work for her by getting on the phone,
organizing a birthday party,
you know,
getting,
getting stuff,
you know,
calling up ans and asking,
do they have any children's toys?
She says,
my children complain that I'm on the phone all the time,
texting.
But really I'm organizing their birthday parties.
When my mother was on the phone,
I could hear her life.
I could hear that she was doing things for me and our family and food and
friendships and did,
part of the problem with the privacy of what we do on our phones is that we
don't see that we're actually doing things for each other.
So,
I mean,
I'm just so moved by your saying,
I could hear,
but my wife was dealing,
so it's very complicated.
This whole,
uh,
this whole,
this whole part of how texting takes us away from each other in this other way
is just something that people are starting to study now.
Well,
listen,
thank you very much.
You've been a great audience.
Sorry about my phone,
my phone etiquette.
Thank you very much.
Okay.